[Music]
first on CBS this morning were revealing
Forbes third annual list of America's
richest self-made women celebrate 60 who
earned their own well through success
and innovation to qualify women must
have a minimum net worth of 260 million
dollars tied for third place on this
year's list her Oprah and Judy love
there was coke duty love by the ways
co-founder of love's travel stops and
Country stores in second position is
Dianne Hendrick she's co-founder of ABC
supply roofing company and first on the
list is Little Caesars co-founder Marian
Ilitch forms assistant managing editor
that's Lisa Kroll is here welcome back
hi gal thanks everything we're glad
you're here that the number one position
is someone from Little Caesars Pizza
yep was you know she and her husband
started the business together back in
1959 which was fairly unusual and she
was involved in the operations the
entire time and they had a rare
partnership and that continued she
actually jumps up in the ranks because
her husband passed away in February and
so she inherited you know now takes
control of the rest of Little Caesars
five newcomers to the list who stands
out Jamie currently much she was a
broadcast journalist like you guys and
she had a skin condition that made her
skin really red and so she started
trying to figure out ways to come up
with makeup this was less than ten years
ago she came up with something called IT
cosmetics and L'Oreal bought it from her
for 1.2 billion in cash in August why
she's staying on as CEO the first female
CEO in the company's 108 year history I
mean what a great story yeah and when
you mentioned that these have to be
women who either were part of starting
the company yes they have to be even
though he inherited their husband's part
portion they could also be a CEO like
Meg Whitman who grew a bay from 8
million to you know billions but you
can't have inherited any of the money
you can't have been brought in by your
husband or your father
so harm how hard is it to be a self-made
woman because you look at the list some
of their things seem so simple well I
think it's really yeah I cover who do
you have on the cover yes so there's a
woman named Carolyn Raphael
and her father did costume jewelry but
she started a totally different business
doing cocktail rings and stuff and when
that her father's business wasn't doing
well she started making these bracelets
yes your just say where now there are
new art Luiza because they come up with
a need don't they well they come up with
a need I think that they're basically
solving things that we all think that we
want and we're willing to buy but we
never come you know we don't stick with
it and the founder of California baby a
lot of moms know that product exactly
and so basically she was so upset with
the toxins that she saw in the baby
shampoos she started mixing it herself
she got it long from her own mother and
she set up her own manufacturing
facility she brought in no investors I
mean it sounds incredibly simple but
that is a very hard thing to do this is
such a good issue congratulations thanks
so much
Nora Lisa Kroll thank you